hi guys I had another question on what
is the best vegan source of vitamin b12
okay let's talk about that now there's
three main sources of b12 that a lot of
vegans consume one is nori which is red
algae chlorella and spirulina but there
are there's two types of b12 there's a
pseudo b12 and there's like real b12 so
pseudo means it's like a fake b12 and
it's called a b12 analogue what that
means it's similar in chemistry but not
very similar in function so if an algae
has larger amounts of pseudo b12 or b12
analogue that is going to block that
small bit of trace real b12 that's in
there and you're going to end up with
the deficiency so unless you're
consuming extra b12 from a supplement or
something I do not recommend trying to
get your b12 from nori or spirulina on
the other hand chlorella has much
greater amounts of actual real b12 and
very trace amounts of the pseudo
analogue b12 so then the question is how
much chlorella do you need to get your
daily requirement of b12 you would need
six tablets or one teaspoon
twice per day thanks for watching hi
guys hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause so take
the quiz now and we'll send you a report